[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road
2000 as always my name is caleb denby
and tonight
i am very excited to talk to you guys
about one
vladimir kramnik and how for
a couple decades there he seemed to win
every game with the white pieces
in the catalan of course i'm
exaggerating a little bit
but of course kramnik is well known
for changing the face of modern openings
in modern day chess at the top level he
revived the catalan
he brought you the berlin and
he's known for much much more of course
that's his biggest legacy
on uh openings these days the berlin and
the catalan
don't seem to be going anywhere anytime
soon so why do i want to talk to you
about
specifically vladimir kramnik's catalan
today why not just the catalan
in general and part of the reason why i
want to focus
on kramnik in particular where uh is
number one he was so good at it
and number two it could be a great way
to get a feel for an opening
to pick you know sort of a specialist in
that opening and go through their games
see how they are adapting their
repertoire
against each of the main lines against
your opening so we're going to see
how kramnik wants to respond to the main
defenses
against the catalan and see if we can
find some consistency there
because a great player's repertoire
tends to be kind of consistent they're
going for similar ideas
in different positions and that makes it
a lot easier to play a lot easier to
keep track of and i think kramnik does a
good job of it here
in the catalan so to start off with i
want to take a look at this game
between kramnik and alexander marozovic
kramnik starts with the ready move order
with one knight f3
but we get back to the normal catalan
stuff soon enough we get c4
e6 g3 d5
and d4 uh of course just transposing
to a mainline catalan so kramnik of
course
uh hints that he's going to play the
catalan with this move g3 preparing to
fee and cut of the bishop
and then it is just a catalan and not an
english
once uh the pawn lands on the d4 square
so like i said we're going to take a
look at a lot of the main
defenses to the catalan but in this game
we're going to see what happens
if uh black calls white a dummy
because this pawn on c4 is attacked and
in fact
not defended because white is developing
the bishop out
to the g2 square this bishop is not
going to be recapturing on c4
as it would in a typical queen's gambit
that's sort of the whole point here
we're bringing the bishop to the long
diagonal not the c4 square
so in this case mirozovic is going to
take on c4 and try to hold on to this
pawn
and find compensation that way for the
super powerful
bishop kramnik of course is just going
to continue out now with bishop to g2
you can also play the quieter move point
a4 check if you're really worried about
getting this pawn back but bishop g2 is
normal
a6 now by mirozovic is preparing to
defend this guy
we get knight e5 a bishop b4 check to
develop with tempo
knight c3 and now knight d5
so what black has done in this opening
is taken on c4
very early on and is now trying to use
some active play
against white's king before white is
comfortably castled
to sort of stunt this bishop on g2 and
hold on to this pawn
on c4 so as kramnik here
what do you think we should do can we
get away
with castling our king in this position
can we get away with it
four allows e5 so yeah on those first
few moves
kramnik uh of obviously swapped between
a lot of
different move orders for the first
three moves he was comfortable playing
the ready with one knight f3 and
comfortable allowing
the ensuing positions so uh if you don't
want to get tricked into random ready
positions you can start with one d4 and
play the catalan like that
it's just a matter of which lines you're
looking to avoid on the day
braywolf thought kramnik was known for
being tall it turns out
kramnik was known for at least two
things then
at least two
a little bit later in the lecture we'll
learn that he was also known for going
to the bathroom a lot in his world
championship matches but that's beside
the point
that's beside the point
so of course in this position as we're
still
getting rolling here we have kingside
castles by
white you know you don't really have to
worry so so much about this pawn on c3
it turns out that black can in fact
capture it
but it's perfectly in line with our game
plan to bring this rook to b1
when all of a sudden you see that the
the activity on the light squares
is already beginning to sort of come to
a head here this b7 pawn is going to
fall
white's going to have a ton of
compensation and black is not really
even going to be able
to hold on to the extra material play
could continue with something like queen
takes d4
queen a4 check b5 queen a3
and things just get wild from here on
out the rook is attacked the queen on
the knight in e5 is attacked
we have an in-between move bishop f4
bishop c7
and this is one of those lines where you
kind of have to know everything and then
maybe black's okay so definitely not
what uh
mirozovich was looking for in in this
game just want to highlight
that this stuff does exist and you
should take a look at it if you are
thinking of playing like this
with kingside castles in the game though
mirozovich picks
the more normal move kingside castles
for black this knight c3 line honestly
probably isn't that great for for black
from what i've seen of it
and uh castles should be a little bit
better
in my opinion okay now in the game we do
have castles and the knight on c3 is
still attacked
so white plays queen c2 just to defend
the knight
now black plays b5 and
we have to find some way to mount an
attack
on the light squares that's going to be
the common thread that's going to be the
consistent thing
throughout all the games we look at
today kramnik
finds some way no matter what black does
to mount an attack
on the light squares and i think that's
the most instructive thing
you can take away from his treatment of
the catalan
so as white how do we break through
on the light squares we need to come up
with some kind of plan here
ah and great wolf is unaware of the
infamous
infamous toilet gate as it was so named
from 2007 2006. not 2007.
great wolf says a4 and yeah you're
definitely on the right track here
great wolf um you you want to be able to
break down
black's structure somehow but if you
play a4 directly
i don't think it's going to be going to
be quite enough here we'll take a look
at that
in in a moment biggie big e says a4
or e4 so something
to note is that this bishop only attacks
dark squares
and this knight is applying pressure to
the light squares so it's not always in
white's best interest to allow this move
bishop takes c3 it doesn't seem like
something
you should really be all that concerned
about but
if black does get to play bishop takes
c3 in some positions
then your pressure on the light squares
is going to be a little bit harder
to maintain for example just play some
slow move like bishop d2
black very well may take on c3
play f6 to eject our knight and then all
of a sudden
we're attacking none of black's light
squares
so kramnik took a look at this in the
game and he realized that now is
actually the correct
time to capture on d5 which might not be
a move
that strikes out to most people at first
at first glance of course black is going
to take back on d5 and now it looks as
though
our light squared attack is sort of
falling behind here you know white is
black is making quite the wall with all
of the pawns on light squares and it's
going to be tough to break through
we'll see what happened there in a
moment but let's take a look at this
move a4
first i think with a4 again it's going
to be a similar thing where black is
able to take on c3 perhaps
eject our knight and again continue out
with bishop b7
and again we just are not really
mounting that much pressure without this
knight on c3
so that's why kramnik plays the
unexpected knight takes d5
it's a really important move when you
sort of understand
the consistency in this light squared
pressure that kramnik is going for
you know it might not be a move that you
consider at first
but uh it's perfectly in line with
kramnik's plan
and you'll notice that every move
priming place from here on out
is an assault on blacks light squared
pawns and light squares in general so e
takes d5 now how do we continue
the assault on the pawns
how do we continue here
keep in mind this one annoying move i
kept playing
we're gonna have to get cr get pretty
creative in order to uh
to get around this one move sort of
stopping our play
so e4 is being suggested and yeah e4
again
the problem is going to be this annoying
move that i keep bringing up this move
f6 is surprisingly very very important
defensive resource
for black here the second f6 gets played
if we can't do something special
we're just going to have to retreat our
knight and then after a simple move like
bishop b7
you know what what are we doing with
this pawn our pawn is attacked so we're
going to go e5 are we going to take
and activate our opponent's pieces our
light squared assault is not going so
well
so kramnik finds some way to very
creatively
make make this f6 move not so much of a
problem
yeah i know but but ben feingold says
ben feingold says
ngif says a4 again a4 f6 we need
something better
a3 is a tempo so i don't think a3 is
going to be
the most helpful to us it doesn't really
spoil too much but
our opponent's bishop might actually be
happier back here on a5
where it can drop back to this diagonal
apply a little bit of pressure to
our d pawn so yeah it i
it doesn't really gain a tempo or lose a
tempo you spend a move on a3 opponent
spends a move on on bishop a5
and the rest sort of sits
so melo has the correct move b3 but what
is the
idea if black were to play f6 here this
is important what is the point
because if you just play knight f3 here
you have all the same problems as before
black can play any number of moves
and be perfectly happy with his position
so what was the point why was b3
so necessary
mole says go i don't know what that
means
i don't know what that means what's our
point here
uh burrito says couldn't the pawn on b2
go to b4 and trap or get the bishop
take the bishop i think you're talking
about in that a3 line
the bishop would go back here to b6 in
response to b4
just apply a little bit more pressure
can we play b take c4 that's exactly
correct b
takes c4 is the very important idea
and if black had played f6 this would
simply be a winning idea here if you
capture the knight
i'm gonna take on d5 with check
and take your rook and you can try
something like
c6 but you're not really going to keep
my my bishop trapped for too long here
my queen is going to help out
and black is busted so bc4 the really
important idea
this is why kramnik is playing b3 here
playing very very actively
because black has tried to hold on to
this extra pawn
when black tries to play against the
catalan like it's a gambit like this to
hold onto the pawn
you do have to come up with some very
active ideas
but again the central theme is always
going to be attacking on
the light squares so mirozovich comes up
with the best move here in the form of
pawn to c6
just simply solidifying building the
pawn diamond of power
and again we need to break through what
can we do here
ben feingold was right after all it
turns out uh it's just that white has to
know what he's doing
uh in order to punish f6 properly
samurozovich is no slouch he's not
playing f6 he's not going to lose the
game like that
arrested says now e4 and again this is
the move
that kramnik plays in the game however
things are a little bit different after
f6 now we've played this move e4
our opponent has defended this pawn a
little bit better
and our bishop doesn't quite have such
easy access to the d5 square
so what's the deal mirozovic actually
does play f6 now
and we need an idea here what's our
point
con connor mccormick says still b takes
c4
and he's almost correct
um maybe b takes c4 is just as good
but it there might actually be an
important difference yeah so ag says e
takes d5 or silver
i guess i don't know maybe a g um
and e takes d5 is what is played in the
game and now you might be thinking hold
on a second your knight's attacked
and you're actually just totally right
this is a p
sacrifice by vladimir kramnik and
again it just goes to show his
commitment to the plan here we are
assaulting
the light squares no matter the cost so
e takes d5
and then following that up with b takes
c4 we don't care about this pawn we want
to rip open the light squares get after
this rook and activate our catalan
bishop
now why not b take c4 immediately here
i think perhaps black would consider
actually taking back on c4
and giving you maybe potentially some
more problems after all your d pawn is
hanging
there are other ideas associated with
that as well and you do have to do
something with this knight so ed5
instead
now c uh b takes c4 black takes as many
pawns as possible with e takes d4
and now we get d takes c6 white also
coming crashing through now
by the way we do have a threat our
threat is c7
attacking the rook attacking the queen
attacking the knight can't defend them
all
and black comes up with this nice move
bishop e6 here
so what's the point of bishop e6
what do you guys think we should play
with the white pieces here
great wolf says how do you judge if this
peace sack is
sound or not i'm not going to lie to you
i think
kramnik had this one prepared prior
prior to this game this one would be a
pretty tough one to just sort of
intuitively come up with on on the spot
that being said
it just comes down to calculation right
um
you should be able to calculate f6 take
take take take you should be able to get
here pretty easily on your own
um and then thinking in your head you
know obviously everybody's at different
levels but as far as
calculating long lines go this one was
pretty forcing and then after this
you might realize that d take c is
really your only idea
and then if you are thinking here you
can't find a good move for black and you
think you
you're going to be able to win some
material back then that's the moment
when i would say
you can consider actually going for the
piece sacrifice
obviously that's going to be difficult
in a real game if you don't feel very
well prepared
but um that's the best advice i can
offer
on judging sacrifices calculate
calculate calculate
and then if you get to the end and you
feel good about your position
might as well give it a go so nick fell
for my trap i told you c7 was the answer
and then it's actually not the answer
here so why not c7 well
black has taken quite a lot of material
at this point and after queen takes c7
we do play bishop takes a8 the simple
move is queen takes c4
if we go for a trade all of a sudden
this rook is trapped
and black is is simply better if we go
rook d1
the only square we can go bishop b2
and bishop c3 actually apparently bishop
b2 is wrong we can go bishop c
through first and then bishop b2 and
that's the better move order
nowhere to go for this rook all stuck
alone
on the first rank so pretty wild stuff
pretty wild stuff to see coming but
kramnik saw it
in advance and he said you know what
i'm going to stay down the piece and i'm
going to just play
my position so he comes up with the
incredible move c takes b5
and notably
white's last four moves we're taking all
of these pawns
so just incredible assault on these
light squares here
um mirozovich comes up with this move d3
and unfortunately
this is uh the quote-unquote losing
move you know it's not entirely lost yet
but uh mirozovich's position is going to
be pretty tough to to save after this
one
what should he have done instead
honestly it's already pretty tough
the best move in the position i think is
rook a7
um and the idea is pretty simple
it's that c7 was a threat and you have
to stop it somehow
but looking at this knight on b8 it's
it's already going to be a difficult
uphill battle
for um for black here for example rook
b1
is threatening to push b6 and then we
can activate our pieces
activate activator pieces and this rook
honestly maybe shouldn't even be saved
um
sad stuff i guess bishop b6 is probably
the the move here
but uh it's already a difficult position
for black
to be sure instead though we get the
more forcing move
d3 now what's wrong with d3 white to
move here
white to move
what can we do
and yeah now c7 is in fact the correct
idea uh why is it better now well queen
take c7 has been stopped
thanks to our last move c takes b5 our
queen is now active on the c file it's
going to be another common theme we see
in kramnik's games here this queen on
the c file
is a very very important piece a very
important attacking piece
on the c file now of course if you were
to capture my queen i would simply
capture your queen
capture your rook and now bishop c4
isn't going to be quite as scary as
before
we simply develop give you back uh this
rook if you want it
and attack your rook in exchange if you
save your rook
going i don't really even know here i'll
just play rook c1
and it's too difficult for you to uh to
keep everything together here
and as for the material account i'm
already up in exchange
and one pawn for now
probably i'm gonna be up one pun at the
end of the day and so
if i have to give back the exchange i
certainly can
and uh white's going to be just winning
so what was the point the point is that
d takes c2
not a good move what mirozovich came up
with is queen d4
but now unfortunately kramnik seals the
deal here
sacrificing this rook on a1 with this
move queen a4
again all these moves occurring on the
light squares or with the theme
of attacking the light squares opening
up the light squares queen a4
now knight d7 if you thought about
taking this rook on a1
you thought wrong we can take on a8 but
even better
is capturing on b4 leaving this rook
just hanging
and obviously your k7 isn't really doing
much for you either
also rook a7 i think i can take this and
take this
very good um so queen a4 and you can't
take the rook on a1
the knight on b8 is still hanging so we
get knight d7
trying to defend this rook on a8 as well
but at this point things are getting
very very sad for black very very
quickly bishop e3
develops with tempo queen d6
we take the rook now bishop f4 defends
the pawn
and attacks the queen
queen back to f8 now b6 and
this is sort of the end of the game here
you cannot play knight takes b6
because queen c6 attacks
three things at the same time i guess
the
the work on a isn't quite as important
but uh very good move
so knight e5 was played but now these
two pawns are going to be enough to win
mirozovich goes for some sort of
checkmate idea on the light squares
but it's obviously not going to be
enough f3 puts a stop
to the czech meeting idea and mirozovich
resigns here so very very impressive
game
by vladimir kramnik now you know the the
point i want you to take away from this
game
isn't this crazy peace sacrifice it
makes the game more interesting when
there's a fun piece sacrifice
and uh you know kramnik uh continues
sacrifice and continues playing actively
in order to win
the point i want you to take away though
is this assault on the light squares
this
almost tunnel vision on opening up the
light squares activating your catalan
bishop
and playing for the advantage in that
way because if you pay attention
all the games we look at tonight are
going to share this theme
of just an assault on the light squares
no matter what
black is doing and that's what the
catalan is all about
so let's continue on now i want to take
a look at another game
this time it's going to be kramnik
versus peter svidler
we're going all the way back to the 90s
for this one 1998
both of these players a lot younger back
then a lot fresher and the catalan
a lot newer of an idea at the top level
of course it saw some use
um i think kasparov played it a couple
times back in the 80s
but it didn't really stick around at the
top level too too much
and kramnik is the guy who uh brought it
back
so let's take a look here we have
kramnik with white pieces playing knight
f3 we get knight f6
and again transposing to our catalan
with
d4 on move four now bishop e7 bishop g2
castles castles and d takes c4 so
d takes c4 in this game a lot like
mirozovich's game
but notably black was a little bit more
responsible with the king in this case
playing bishop b7 and castling before
taking on c4
white also has completed castling and is
now going to
try to pick up the pawn uh with queen c2
so it's not too late for black to go a
little bit crazy with b5
try and hold on to some material but
those lines get very very complex
much much more common in this case is
the move a6
which is what svidler played in the game
now what's the point here well
the point is that black did yes take on
c4
but rather than try to hold on to the
pawn black is going to try to use
the extra tempi that white spends
recapturing it
in order to finish activating his pieces
and counteract
white's powerful powerful powerful light
squared bishop
so this is you know while we do see d
take c4 in this game as well it's a
pretty different plan
than what we saw in game one mirozovic
wanted to keep the pawn wanted to build
a wall
and have extra material peter swiddler
in this case playing a little bit more
with the tempe trying to finish
development
trying to counteract white's bishop now
in the game we see the move queen takes
c4
these days people are leaning more
towards this move a4
in order to stop the line we see in the
game with b5
a4 and the idea of course is just to put
a little bit more pressure
on black's position and keep black from
from playing b5
quite so easily obviously the downside
is that you have to spend a tempo
playing the move a4
uh in the game though just queen takes
c4 b5 queen back to c2
and bishop b7 uh so
seemingly svidler has done everything he
needs to do
he put the bishop opposite this bishop
no way
the light squares are going to come
under fire anymore you know blacks
certainly must be out of the woods
because the bishop made it to the
diagonal of course
that's not going to be not going to be
the case here
so there's a second idea i mentioned in
the previous game that's going to show
up a lot and that idea is the c
file and that is what kramnik takes
advantage of here
to keep the pressure up and eventually
use the c file to apply even more
pressure
on this light square diagonal so with
all that in mind
white to move here what do you think
kramnik's most
testing option is there's obviously a
few moves here they're all
perfectly fine but i do think kramnik's
option is perhaps one of the more
testing ideas
one of the more testing ideas
so nick says bishop d2 to a5
and oyster says bishop f4 as does arcos
so
everybody has the idea of attacking the
pawn on
c7 i'm not so sure i see the argument
for bringing the bishop out this way
you might be concerned about what
svidler played in the game
but we'll see that that idea is perhaps
not so strong so i like bishop f4
it does it in one move while this would
take obviously two moves
now you might have been concerned about
this move knight d5 which is actually
what was played in the game because this
attacks your bishop on f4
and a lot of players might not be so
reluctant to give up this bishop
now of course we are catalan players the
dark squared bishop is
nothing to us all we care about is this
light squared bishop of course i'm
exaggerating a little bit
but we'll see in this game that kramnik
does just fine
while also allowing swiddler the
opportunity to take here
on f4 now this knight d5 idea i'm
actually not the biggest fan of it
by svidler in this game i think the
main move which is knight c6 is going to
give black a lot better
opportunities to equalize and
honestly in these lines where white
doesn't play a4 i don't think black has
too much trouble
getting an equal game with this idea of
knight c6
what's the point well the point is we
have dealt with the pressure to our c7
pawn
by the way that was the point of bishop
f4 making use of the queen
we've dealt with the pressure by
interfering with the queen's axis
to this pawn we're also applying a
little bit of pressure to the center
ourselves
and after a simple move like rook to c1
we actually have a nice tactical idea of
playing this move knight to b4
what's the point of knight b4 well we're
rerouting our knight to d5
with a perfectly strong blockade and you
can't quite get away with taking on c7
because i will take take and trap your
rook here
on a1 so this move knight c6 honestly
i think leaves white with a little bit a
few too many problems
to consolidate into an advantage but
svidler instead going for knight d5 a
more direct approach
sticking this knight on light squares
going after the bishop
and keeping the game flowing now how do
we continue
well we see knight c3 by kramnik this
move
shouldn't really surprise you again this
is the the best square
in this line for the knight as we are
just applying
very very very direct pressure to this
knight on d5
now i will say sometimes you'll see this
knight go knight bd2 and knight
b3 and the idea there is to keep this
pawn backwards on c7 but in this case
we're sticking with the light squared
assault attacking this knight on d5
spidler moves the knight captures on f4
we get g takes f4
i also want to point out this structure
while it does have some weaknesses in it
is actually not really one you need to
be super worried about
it gives you very very excellent control
over the e5 square
very excellent central control it
doesn't actually weaken your king
too too much especially with this bishop
on g2 still being alive
so while you know you should in general
avoid double pawns in this case these
are some pretty useful double pawns it
gives you a lot of mobility
as well controlling the e5 square while
also you know toying with a few
different pawn breaks in the position
black now continues with knight d7 the
idea now being to go
out to b6 and try to set up a blockade
on
d5 or f6 is perhaps a little bit more
natural than b6
same idea though what are we going to do
now
with the white pieces you know we've
given up our dark squared bishop in
exchange for a knight
we need to find some way to keep putting
on the pressure
to the light squares but we don't want
to be too too hasty here so
what are some ideas
like karpov's immortal yeah of course
karpov perhaps has the most famous
light squared assault with uh i can
never remember the real name of it
something like white key symphony
symphony on the white keys or something
they tried to bring like music into it
but uh karpov of course has a very
famous game
against kasparov where he plays you know
15 sum moves all on the light squares
and that's the common theme here in
these games as well
knight e4 not my favorite move of all
time to be honest
um black actually has a pretty
interesting idea
that you might not be familiar with if
you haven't seen it before
but keeping in mind the light squared
assaults it might make a little bit more
sense so knight e4
black actually has a couple moves that
he can play here rook c8
for example is simple enough and
continues preparing the c5 push
but f5 is actually a very very
reasonable and very decent move here
for black by committing this bishop to
the long diagonal it's going to be
pretty difficult for white to actually
apply meaningful
pressure to this pawn on on e6 and if we
do continue
just by retrieving the knight either to
g3 or c3
i'm just going to play c5 i'm going to
break in the center and
it's going to be black taking over on
some of these light squares now
so knight e4 interesting idea not going
to do it for me though i just want to
stick with this mover
f to d1 now how is this move of
increasing our pressure to the light
squares well we'll see
in a little bit how this rook can in
fact be very very useful
of course though we can immediately see
white is hinting at ideas
of d5 attacking the light squares with
the pawn
and opening the d file now in the game
smither plays a move that is quite
frankly just unconscionable
uh i can't recommend this uh playing
like this with black to anybody
and frankly you know i recommend that
children hide their eyes
from the next move it hurts to see i
have no idea why you did it um well
actually it's a lie i have some idea but
he plays bishop takes f3
and bishop takes f3 is just the the
catalan player's dream
now your your super powerful bishop is
quite simply unopposed
and the light squares are eventually
going to fall
so why does fiddler do it why oh why
does he play
bishop takes f3 well i think what he was
concerned about
is if you play the more normal looking
move knight f6
with the idea being you just want to set
up this blockade i think spidler was
very concerned
about not seeing the bishop land
somewhere on the diagonal
but instead having to deal with this
knight
jumping into c6 sort of at any moment
but we'll see in the game the knight on
c6 alone
not actually that scary not going to be
super terrifying
staring down this knight on c6 alone now
why is that well we could play a move
like knight
queen d7 we can even play queen e8 and
what's this knight doing here
it's not really able to create any
threats on its own
you know we could even try something
like knight e4 but we're playing a bit
too loose now and i think we're actually
losing some material so i think this is
why spidler chose to take on f3 this
knight landing on e5
just looked too too ugly with this
knight c6 idea always sort of
looming in the position and i don't
think he was very happy with that
now the answer cannot be bishop takes f3
because we'll see that kramnik has a
very very clever idea
to uh not only increase the pressure but
sort of blow slither out of the water in
this game so of course we take back with
the bishop
and now we get rook b8 of course this
rook is now under attack
since the light square bishop is missing
from black's camp
uh now uh kramnik plays a very
solidifying move that is very very
common for this structure
just e3 making sure that black doesn't
have any
funny tactics any funny threats against
f4
now play continues with knight f6 so
they're very calmly
or sorry kramnik very calmly please work
a to c1 increasing the pressure
to c7 again the c file a very very
important idea here
for white as well queen d6 played in the
game
and now i want you to find kramnik's
amazing
re-route and uh certain
you know semi-long-term plan it only
takes him a few moves to pull off this
plan
but black is quite frankly helpless to
to stop it so see if you can come up
with the plan that kramnik enacted here
to just demolish swiddler on the light
squares
all right a4 has been suggested a4 isn't
quite right here
we're more concerned with this diagonal
and
using and abusing the squares on this
diagonal you know
attacking a4 honestly might even help
attacking with a4 might help black more
than white here opening up the b
file
so if we combine everybody's in
everybody in the chat seems to have a
different idea
um and i think together they all make
one really great idea in the form of
kramnik's plan so this move92
i think is really really excellent and
this is what uh kramnik plays in the
game
tactically by the way knight to f's
knight to e4
is in fact going to be a very good
option black is going to have to take
this knight
if you move the queen back out of the
way and then of course queen c7
this is just hanging so you have to take
this guy and then you have to play this
move f5 in order to not lose a pawn
in rook fc8 in this move i mean this
position is still
very very very uncomfortable for black
this bishop is
simply no match for the light squared
bishop on f3
however svidler i'm sorry kramnik chose
this move in id2
and i like this better it keeps the
knights on the board and
kramnik's next few moves are are very
very convincing svither plays this move
rook f to c8 and now e4
uh that's the idea of the knight i need
to defending these
loose squares and then getting ready to
push through with e4
uh svidler now has to so i'm sorry i
should mention
knight e2 by the way attacks c7 as well
which is why you see this move rook fc8
by
uh svidler you have to defend the pawn
now e4
makes another threat everything is
coming with tempo
queen d7 stepping out of the fork and
now d5
and this is just uh just terrifying
stuff at this point
you know svidler all those moves ago
played bishop takes f3 to stop a knight
from landing on e5 and
later c6 and now after e takes d5
of course what is kramnik's idea
what is kramnik's idea just laughing in
svidler's face after he went to such
great lengths
to make sure a knight didn't land on c6
and yet oyster has the right idea once
again
just the wrong notation i think oyster
is trying to say e5
and this is the perfect move of course
we do not
want to play e takes d5 leaving these
pawns
doubled and isolated and giving our
opponent a great opportunity
to actually shut our bishop out of the
game once again
we want to play e5 keeping the diagonal
as open as possible
forcing this knight back to e8 now we
take on d5
with the diagonal still open queen h3
bishop g2 is the tempo queen h4
and now simply knight d4 this knight's
landing on c6
and this time it's not on its own it's
got this bishop backing it up
the rooks are going to be entirely
trapped on
their own back rank uh kramnik also has
taken over the d
file as well as the half open c file and
black's pieces are just
miserable here black does have one thing
going for him and that is that the f
pawn is hanging
spidler captures that pawn and says uh
you know i've taken your pawn
and of course now knight c6 is very very
strong
and the bishop comes out to h4 and again
we see black just going for
some kind of last minute desperate
attacks on the king's side of course
it's not going to be enough here
and the next three moves i think are
very very funny so
chat what do you think knight takes b8
uh should we play it
should we not play it what's the story
here
what's the story here knight takes b8
free rook right
so i'm being a little bit mean of course
knight takes b8 is entirely winning
but when you see the game continuation
you would feel very very foolish if you
uh had actually captured the the rook on
b8 the game continuation kramnik simply
doubles on the d
file lets the rook hang it's not like
black is going to be much better if
you spend a move playing uh rook rook b
to a8
so rook c to d1 and we're actually
making some threats here
against the bishop on h4 and so for
those next two moves of course
are rook b6 orc d4 and rook takes c6
so you saved yourself two tempe by uh by
letting spidler play rook b6 where it
takes c6 for you
rather than playing knight takes b8 now
we get bishop takes c6 and the game
doesn't last much longer
spidler takes an e5 we get bishop d7 or
d8
android takes h4 and it's not even worth
counting the pieces
spidler just had had enough at this
point and threw in the towel
so another very impressive game by
kramnik again
the common thread here is activating
this light squared bishop
on this main diagonal and just cruising
through crushing
the opponents now i think we have time
to take a look
at uh sort of a miniature it's not
really a miniature but kramnik
got a winning position straight out of
the opening and
that is the third approach to the
catalan that i sort of want to talk
about
so in this game kramnik is up against
arcadia knightich
and nidish is just having none of this
catalan
nonsense uh he takes advantage of
cranmix move order by playing an early
c5
to prevent uh you know the classic
catalan setup
now uh what's the problem with that well
after d4
we hit c takes d4 and so this is
obviously something
that would not be allowed in the more
traditional
catalan setup so
what are we doing as kramnik here well
kramnik isn't flinching
simply bishop g2 same plan as always we
attack the light squares
knight itch plays e6 shoring up the
center we get castles by white
and knight h now continues to blow
things up in the middle
and plays d takes c4 so this is pretty
different than the mainline catalans
that we were looking at before
in this case knight hitch has opted for
the most direct
the fastest play just blowing up the
center before white gets a chance
to do any of the funny setups
that catalan players know so well so
what do we do in this case how do we
take advantage of knight edge's play
well it's not going to be anything all
that special we're going to see kramnik
again
quite simply attack the light squares
work to regain the pawns
and then we'll see knight edge misses
some pretty fun tactics
pretty early on here so the d4 pawn is
hanging we should take it back
we get knight d5 and now kramnik takes
the time to play queen a4
check and capture the other pawn back on
c4
so after knight 7 to b6 our queen's
attacked so queen
to b3 now bishop d7 and the question is
what has black's immediate play really
done for him
and the answer is not all that much
black's king is still stuck in the
center
white has gotten castled and it's not as
if uh
this bishop is any less powerful than it
would be in the normal catalan
knightitch is trying to justify it by
saying he got this nice blockade
with these two knights on the d5 square
and is ready to play something like
bishop c6 to neutralize the bishop
but of course kramnik is just not going
to give him
that chance once again we see this
knight coming out to c3
and i really want to highlight this move
because it's not just a normal
developing move here
of course it does develop the piece but
this knight is critically important as
an attacker
on the d5 square and after bishop takes
or bishop c5 you're going to see this
knight once again
doing an early capture on the d5 square
in order to
soften up black's position so knight
takes d5
knight takes d5 and now white to move
and
find a very very strong continuation
here
very strong
very strong play here by vladimir
kramnik
and yeah apologies uh again for um
however badly i am mispronouncing knight
itch's name
i will never learn supriya
gets kicked out of the class for
suggesting bishop
takes d5 giving away the catalan bishop
are you insane
of course we want to keep this bishop
and just kidding supriya you can stay
but this bishop is our hopes and dreams
we don't want to get rid of it but of
course
the move knight f5 taking advantage of
this idea
of the bishop's pressure on the light
squares knight f5 is just
very very strong here and knight h quite
simply
is much worse if you capture this knight
we're going to see queen takes d5 all
pieces hanging
for black and white it's going to go up
material pretty early on here
so instead we get castles and what is
the stellar
follow-up that i'm sure you guys all saw
when you played knight f5
what's the follow up here the knockout
punch
with the knight on f5 of course
you don't get to stop calculating after
e takes f5 you have to have some plan
for if black ignores you and just
castles
so what is that plan
nick says bishop takes knight in queen
c3 and that's going to be a
an important part of the correct move
but not quite correct
you can do better of course
one problem with that line is that
queen c3 the knight on f5 is hanging so
you get this bishop on c5
and you might be a little bit better but
it's not
quite as good as you can do
oyster says knight h6 check even better
the knight
h6 check is knight takes on g7
and this move is the move that gives
kramnik the the winning position here
so knight takes g7 if you take this guy
i'm gonna take on d5 e takes d5
and now queen c3 and as before we are
uh picking up the bishop on c5 we've
just taken an extra g7 pawn along the
way
and this is just way too strong in the
game
knight hitch plays knight f6 and kremnik
has a little bit of
trouble uh extricating this knight but
does manage to do it after all we see
him bring the queen over
uh over here now to h4 uh
night itch comes up with knight to g8
the idea is to
remove the defender of the knight and
then we see kramnik sort of bailing out
with takes
takes and takes getting the rook for the
two pieces
and after it takes c6 white has
one two three pawns and a rook for two
pieces
which is plenty to go on to win the game
so really early opening kill by kramnik
here
and again the common theme as always an
assault on the light squares knight f5
for the critical move
all right and with that we have only 10
minutes left but i do want to go
over the uh game i sort of teased at
the top of the hour and that is kramnik
versus topolov
from their infamous match in 2006.
for those of you unfamiliar of course
kareem nick did go on to win this match
but it was not without controversy uh
there were some accusations
of frequent bathroom trips of course the
computer
computer era was dawning in the chess
world
and there was a little bit of paranoia
going on i think but
uh and and so in in response kramnik
forfeited game five refused to play a
move
but did end up to to to go on to win the
match anyways
so ignoring all that controversy this
was one of the games that they played in
the match and i wanted to walk you
through it here so kramnik has white
and plays d4 which should be no surprise
to people
familiar with the 2006 match of course
every game in the 2006 match
started with d4 regardless of colors uh
topolov
played knight f6 we get c4 e6 knight f3
d5
and g3 entering the catalan and now we
are finally going to take a look at
the closed catalan so all of the
previous positions we looked at
were open or open catalans and now we're
going to look at the closed catalan so
what's the point of the closed catalan
well we see black inserts this check we
get bishop d2
and then drops back to e7 and this is
just a little bit of a subtlety
that players have come up with over the
years the point now
is that this bishop is actually in the
way of the queen in the way of the
knight
and not really at all developed on d2
it's going to have to move again to get
developed
and sometimes it would rather be on b2
than c3 so it misplaces the bishop
and then black just continues on with
normal development
we get bishop g2 now by white castles
castles and c6
so the point now for black is that we
are not
playing an early d take c4 because that
seems ridiculous
you know it opens this long diagonal for
our opponent so
topolov in this case choosing the other
approach just
shoring up this pawn on d5 and trying to
stunt this bishop
where it sits on g2 now we get bishop f4
by
white highlighting that black's opening
idea was maybe not so stupid
i'm just moving the bishop again now we
get knight b to d7 by black
simple development and queen c2 by white
again all normal developing moves that
we've seen before a5
rook d1 again this is a very nice square
for the rook to support potential
d5 pushes now knight h5 attacks this
bishop on
on f4 and kramnik is actually going to
drop it all the way back to c1 again
further justifying black's opening play
but
uh that doesn't mean it's a bad move
that just means the black had a
good idea with bishop b4 check
and now we see topolov go for this idea
of b5 trying to immediately
clarify things in the center and on the
queen side we're
forcing white to make a decision with
the c4 pawn
of course white is not interested in
playing something like c5
you don't want to lock things up over
here you want to rip open the light
squares
so we get c takes d5 by kramnik and c
takes d5
by topalov now of course how should we
continue here
with white how to continue with white
how to continue
nick says knight c3 and we can actually
be a little bit more direct
than knight c3 in this case uh and by
the way
topolov's opening play with pushing on
the queen side has a couple nice added
bonuses for him one of those being this
move b4 can be rather annoying for white
to deal with so
be on the lookout for that with this
pawn sitting here on
b5 so more active than knight c3
and yeah the chat room is up to the task
here with this move e4
again you just need to open up the light
squares
to play uh play the catalan it's that's
the whole idea
uh of course now uh black was not super
interested
in playing something like bishop b7
let's say because now we might actually
see a little bit of a reversal here
because e5 can be very very awkward to
deal with with this knight sitting here
on h5 of course there's an exception to
every rule and in this case
black's pieces are awkwardly enough
placed that white is willing to play
something like e5
lock down these light squares and rear
out the bishop somewhere else
so bishop b7 not really going to get the
job done what else could you try
something like knight back to f6 again
not going to be the greatest either
we'll simply take on d5
and now something like knight c3 would
be a lot better because we can respond
to b4
with knight takes d5 and again just
keeping pressure up on the light squares
so instead of those options we actually
see uh
topalov capture on e4 drawing white's
queen out
and perhaps trying to highlight the fact
that this is not really the best
orientation for white's pieces
when after rook b8 bishop b7 would come
with tempo
on the white queen that's why we see
kramnik again rerouting the queen now
back to e2 this time we get knight back
to f6 and now bishop the bishop
once again is going to move this time
out to f4 attacking this rook on b8
rook b6 and now we can continue our
attack
on the light squares so how to continue
here
how to continue here
topolov so aggro and yeah that was his
reputation
uh probably still is his reputation if
you ask me
uh topolov one of the most aggressive
one of the most combative tactical
players
of the past 20 years i would say
so knight c3 again would be a reasonable
move but
don't forget you do have to be on the
lookout for these b4 ideas you know
black can even prepare them with
something like bishop a6
and setting you up for some nasty
tactics
and so yeah hassan has the right idea
here with knight
to e5 you want to open up this bishop
and assault these light squares
before topalov is able to
counteract them with a bishop b7 of
course bishop b7 in this case
not going to be good enough we're going
to take and
knight c6 and at the very least
we can take this pawn on a5 we can also
just develop
and this knight is very very powerful
once again
so instead we see this move knight
to d5 and compared to the previous game
topolov has done
much much better in the opening of this
game than
our first three opponents he's gotten
this knight to d5 he hasn't really given
up too much he even has some extra space
on the queen side you know his king's
castle all his pieces are developed
aside from this bishop here on b7
and it seems like for the moment
everything is defended no
clear path for kramnik to break through
and so what happens if we just play a
simple move like knight to c3
well then we're gonna see knight seven
to f6 and all of a sudden
black is achieving a certain harmony in
his position here this knight covers
this knight the queen and the pawn have
d5 well well defended not really getting
anywhere with knight takes d5
um and you know bishop b7 is going to
come out soon
bishop a6 could even come out black's
going to expand on the queen side
everything seems to make sense black has
a plan white hasn't broken through
what's the big idea and so
kramnik in this position finds something
immediate
to do so black to move here
how can we turn up the pressure uh
against de pollov
okay the chat's saying knight a3 i don't
really get knight to a3
um i guess you're you're saying that if
b4 gets played i can um
hop to c4 i think though bishop a6 is a
move black wants to play anyways
uh and black might might be ever so
tempted
to even capture this knight and double
your pawns so not knight a3
not quite knight a3
so as we're running a little bit short
on time i'm going to give you the move
it's
bishop takes d5 the move that none of
you should have considered
giving away the catalan bishop so why
does kramnik give away the bishop well
in this case
it's going to come with a double attack
against these pawns
and white is going to be able to go up
upon here
and use that as
his proposed advantage now topalov does
play well for the next few moves knight
f6 take on b5
bishop a6 and a4 but it turns out an
extra pawn is an extra pun
and topolov did go on to lose this game
with kramnik having
the big advantage with the white pieces
i'll scroll through it quickly
we got knight e4 uh kramnik took over
the c file once again
and then just a few retreating moves
were the wrong idea
for topalov here and pretty quickly
things just sort of fell apart with the
powerful knight outposted on b5
yes it's pinned but it also did turn out
to be very very powerful
we saw this weird funky trade with the
pin being made use of
but kramnik takes an extra pawn on d5
and
before too long uh cram or topalov
actually has to sacrifice this rook
on b5 to get rid of the knight and
kramnik pretty easily
went on to win this end game trading
queens and
it turns out rooks are more powerful
than knights and that was enough
to win this game
so once again i hope you guys enjoyed
all of these
catalan games from vladimir kramnik he
popularized popularized the opening in
modern chess
and it's easy to see why he makes it
look very very convincing
and sometimes very very easy to outplay
these world-class
players he just ruthlessly goes after
those light squares
and when it works it works very very
well now if you liked
kramnik playing the catalan you'll like
ulf anderson
playing the catalan uh even more and
hopefully you'll like grand master
dennis borosch even more than me as well
as he
is going to be the next lecture on here
and he's also going to be talking about
the catalan
uh in honor of old anderson's birthday
so that's all i have for you tonight as
always my name is caleb denby i want to
thank you guys
very very much for sticking this one out
with me
uh and as always i will see you next
time
[Music]
you